[Music]
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's gonna be a murder tonight
hey time travel movies never make any
sense
happy Halloween how about we all stay in
and hand out Halloween candy no Mom you
know how hard this time of year is for
us your friends were murdered 35 years
ago it's not 1987 anymore stay safe
honey I love you
[Music]
thank you
what the [__]
excuse me what year is it 1987. oh my
God I know the 80s are almost over and I
haven't even tried Coke yet
I don't know
mom
[__] off and die Jesus mom
um
time for my birthday [__]
this is a creepiest cabin in the middle
of [__] nowhere what's the big deal
there is a murderer on the loose and you
drove us into the woods
I forgot to bring vodka
you have seven and a half hours until
you're stuck here forever
[Music]
all this horror before it happens
machines kill us all no they more just
rip apart the fabric of our society via
dance videos on Tick Tock face dance
against us
come on out the water's warm just so you
know I don't do [__] you pee out of
that thing
I think maybe if she did do [__]
be alive
yeah let's not make that the lesson
80s weed sucks this is just dirt look at
all these Twigs yeah I could give you a
gummy this big it has 100 times more
weed than this
foreign